And if we reload the page, you can see
here that the bars have been converted into circles, and
the axes remain the same, in this case, years, with the label every four years.
And the y axis represents attendance in millions.
And with our scatter plot if we hover we still have the interactive features,
but this time there's both a horizontal and a vertical guideline to animate out.
My ideal choice of chart type in this case is a line plot.
Since the x-axis represents time and
has a natural sequence to it, for any time series data a point at time
t on the x-axis somewhat depends on the time that just came before it.
In this example, 1948 somewhat depends on 1947, which depends on 1946.
And this natural ordering from one year to the next or
from one data point to the next, represents something of a transition.
And the line plot really evokes this interpretation by linking each data
point from one to the next with a graphical element.
In this case a line or a path between the two.
If we go back to our editor.
Remember, we can change what type of plot we're making, or
chart, by simply changing what we pass to add series.
In this case, let's change scatter to line, save our file, and
go back to our browser.
If we refresh the page, we can see here.
Every dot has disappeared and instead we have a line representing the trend.
But one slight formatting quirk of this line plot is
that we no longer know how many data points we actually have.
Especially if dimple didn't provide us with hover interaction.
We wouldn't really know which years and
how much attendance in those years is represented in our data.
And without the hover interaction it would actually be impossible to know
that a World Cup didn't happen in the year 1942, in the year 1946.
Quick fix for this is to actually combine a line plot and
a scatter plot to get the best of both charts and almost none of the down sides.
And dimple again, being the flexible and powerful library that it is,
to achieve this effect we simply just need to add another series.
In this case, with a line and our scatter.
And to draw them on the same set of x and y axes.
Going back to the browser, now we have both the line showing the trend over
the years, and the circles to show us which years games actually happened in,
and what the precise attendance was for those years.
And with our scatter dots we can now see that there were no games
between 1938 and 1950, or rather, that the 1942 and 1946 games were skipped.